we thank you for joining us today is our
special guest we've got Michael Stebbins
who was actually helped before market
motive is kind of the CIO have simply
learned he also has a lot of a
background in the online training helped
to create a lot of the curriculum and
it's just kind of been around Mike for
what about 15 years now at least doing a
lot of these parts with online marketing
and you have a very background with
other businesses as well we're talking
about today with fired hired and the new
digital team skills and structure Mike's
gonna be walking us through a little bit
of kind of what some of the the online
marketplace is working towards kind of
where you see some of these trends are
coming up and as he's been working with
the OU MCP kind of how some of the
market trends are going so he's going to
be describing that we will be making
this recording available that's going to
be online with the simply learn as well
as the market mode of websites so that
you can watch this or share this with
any of your team members we're gonna be
sharing a poll later on that if we can
help you in any way with some of your
business if you find this very helpful
and you're saying hey you know what my
team could use some of this information
or hey you know I'd like to know a
little bit more about what what Michael
does or some same questions that maybe
come up at a later point you can reach
back out to us we will definitely make
those available but our job with with
with simply learned is that we are here
to help educate you and help you educate
your team so we put up these free
webinars to help give you a little
snippet of some of our faculty some of
our staff that have some some teaching
background that we want to make this
available if you have any questions at
any time for you to put that in - feel
free to put that into the chat window or
the questions box and we will do our
best to get through as many of those
questions as possible before we are we
run out of time also if you do have any
issues you can raise your hand and I can
try to reach out to you privately while
Michael is doing some of his
presentation we do ask that if you want
to go live and actually want to speak to
Michael later on and some of the Q&A
session that we can make that available
so if you have your microphone on just
let me know if you have asked a question
if you'd like to go live we can we can
definitely bring you on and you can chat
directly with Mike but if you do have
that please ask us to bring your cell
phones and so on into the mute
category so it doesn't disturb that so
with their Mike let me turn around over
to you and let you go ahead and dr. on
alright thanks Matt you know in the last
few weeks you you actually know Matt
that we sent in over 14,000 of our
family photos and had him scanned by a
company called go photo it's part of
scanned photo and this this weekend was
the first time family members and close
folks close to us were able to look at
some of those photos and you know some
of those 30 year old photos are kind of
embarrassing and I told I told the kids
and the people who were laughing at my
1985 style hey if people aren't laughing
at your 30 year old photo style then you
probably weren't trying hard enough I
haven't seen a 30 year-old once my guy
I've seen some of the ones from the from
the mid-90s but yeah let's just say the
word mullet was being passed around I I
deny it all but you know as we as we
look back at our teams oftentimes we can
sometimes be embarrassed about how we
set them up it's so a midsize company
years ago used to sequester the online
marketing manager off to one side of the
organization and Jessica Bowman of SEO
in-house put out a great report that
showed that in the first 10 to 12 months
that a internet marketer is hired at a
company 80% of their time is spent
practicing their specialty but after 10
to 12 months 80% of their time is spent
trying to influence the rest of the
company into compliance or cooperation
and it's really sad that that type of
influence has to happen and so the
siloing is something that's old and that
we have to get rid of and in some ways
it was even worse at the larger
companies because we would segregate
people into their single discipline and
earlier I was talking about the
one-trick pony
there just is no longer a one-trick pony
the role delineation study from the
industry association Oh MCP
points out that managers you and I and
the people attending insist that they
must hire people who have to two
specialties now in terms of a level
three practitioner and I'll explain what
that is for those of you who aren't
familiar with the OM CP standard that's
simpler a market motive teach to but
they want them to have proficiency in
two disciplines at level three
practitioner and then they want them to
have five of the eight disciplines in an
associate level understanding or
definitional if we're going to make
upwards
understanding of each of those
disciplines five of the eight so these
structures no longer work and what I
really like you to do is to view the
skill sets that your teams need that can
make or break your team over the next
few years into these three areas these
three categories on your obligatory Venn
diagram here and the creative persuasive
is what most people associate with
digital marketing strategic and product
over on the left is very typical
but the ops and data area is a new area
where we're seeing a lot of attention so
let's put a few examples up where we see
product marketing the setting of
business goals the setting of revenue
goals even of margin being strategic and
product oriented and we see the typical
Association of the product strategy and
a product marketing to the more creative
so up top here let's see if we can
highlight a little bit we see branding
PR social media content marketing more
of the creative whereas we see down here
on the lower side web analytics data
collection and data management platforms
is a little bit more of the ops and data
and these are the areas where we're
seeing a lot more growth so we're the
hot new areas that we promised we would
be telling you about but interestingly
they tend to grow see if I can get
control here ago of the screen gif
keyboard
mouse alright man I'm actually stuck
normal drawing mode there we go okay
back on track
alright so the new areas where we're
seeing most of the activity is where ops
data is pushing into the creative and
persuasive
so when ops and data and the new data
that we're able to collect whether it's
implicit or explicit customer behavior
data is now being able to automate the
creative and persuasive for the entire
customer experience so from advertising
all the way to the purchase and all the
way to the support to create a user
experience like no another that makes us
competitive so these are the areas that
managers are looking for the hottest
skills and here are some examples of
what those are so we might look at
social selling customer delight teams
are popping up everywhere now marketing
automation is expanding and we have a
lot of programmatic advertising going on
driven by the behavior data either
on-site or off-site tag management and
DevOps and of course Big Data and data
science are necessary to be able to
drive these types of decisions in these
systems that can push and it's it's very
tough to find these kind of people out
there who already have these skill sets
so we have a gap so not only do we need
the focus on the traditional and then in
the middle column here the core but now
we add to that the complexity of the new
skills and when we're talking to
candidates we might present them with
the landscape or the the types of
technologies that we need to understand
it becomes overwhelming so Scott Brinker
put out a great landscape of some of
them our tech technologies out there and
categorize them and it's it's pretty
overwhelming mark tech that's busy yep
so we'll show this to a prospective
candidate in addition to the other
skills that they need and typically the
reaction is one of just being completely
overwhelmed these skills are skills that
people need to bring up in time so what
do we do as hiring managers to to hire
for these skills and build them in our
team well so far what we've seen work
really well is to focus on the core
areas and then look for the soft skills
that will lend themselves to people
being able to train into these new data
centric skill sets that we need on our
team so this next slide is one that you
may want to capture this is the report
that we've been doing quarterly since
about 2012 and this shows what we as
managers are asking for in aggregate in
terms of the rate of appearance of skill
set words or related words across
hundreds of thousands of full-time
marketing jobs so these are looking for
keyword indicators of demand skills in
full time marketing job postings on
Simply Hired linkedin indeed and
probably several others so for example
this top area here would indicate that
more than half of the jobs posted the
full time marketing jobs require social
media skills whereas about 10% was that
like one and every 11 or so requires SEO
skills and so on down the list so the
interesting changes here are that mark
tech and marketing ops just made the top
10 for the first time in q2 of 2016
displacing conversion and persuasion off
the top 10 list now right away somebody
might say well does that mean conversion
and persuasion are less important than
mark tech and marketing ops it's not
necessarily the case oftentimes things
move off the list because they're
perceived as required it's sort of
expected for example you wouldn't see
the ability to operate a PC on the list
because it's just expected right you
wouldn't see you know the ability to
type I don't like this because that's
expected so that's one reason things
might be a pushed off the list or the
other is a possibility that they might
actually be less expensive absolutely
less less time-consuming or less
important all right so looking at this
list these are the core areas that
managers are posting in jobs things
change a little bit when we go out and
poll managers so let's take this down to
the top seven here off that report so
the top seven skills in demand and these
again focus on the core areas that we
pointed out before but they really don't
seem to address as I mentioned the the
skill sets that we need for data driven
in the Newmark tech skills that our
teams need to succeed right now so when
we go out and survey managers and over
300 managers were surveyed who had
leading teams we asked what is the time
priority of these hard skills in terms
of a average work week for your team and
the results came out quite different in
this case social media which was number
one and remember that was the majority
of the job postings moves down to number
five and web analytics moves up to
number one conversion which didn't make
the top seven or even the top ten now
moves up to number three so why the
difference why is there this difference
between what polled managers will tell
us as a time priority and what's in the
job postings well there's two theories
that were seen float around we don't
know which one is proven yet theory one
is that these things just take more time
web analytics takes much more time and
that I know that you practice web
analytics and it is time consuming to be
able to put together dashboards and
reports and make meaningful decisions
that would imply the social media takes
less time which I don't know if I would
argue for that so that's one theory the
other is is that we know that we can
hire for social media and it's much
harder to hire for web analytics and so
oftentimes we hire people who are
familiar with digital marketing and then
we put them into training programs so
they can practice what we really need
that's another theory that's out there
as well and that process seems to be
working pretty well for folks now things
get even more interesting when we sit
down and talk to managers and in this
case we interviewed 33 managers of teams
that we consider to be exemplary teams
that were leading the market in terms of
performance in terms of innovation and
we asked those managers which hard
skills are required for your team to
succeed and hit next year's goals that
single
which hard skills are required for your
team to hit their numbers and succeed
with nestea next year's goals and the
answers were quite frustrating because
the number one hard skill the managers
would say I want somebody with the
ability to persuade and as the
interviewer this would be quite
frustrating we would say that's nice but
it's not a hard skill will you repeat
the question which hard skills do you
need free teams to succeed and the
manager would come back well ok fine
I'll give up the ability to persuade we
need the ability for people to take
large amounts of data and make key
decisions again this is not a hard skill
give me a hard skill so they'd say ok
how about writing skills well arguably
hard skills could be applied to writing
skills but generally it's considered to
be a soft skill and then they would
throw out something like traditional
marking which you saw that was on the
left side of the Venn diagram those
things in which have been with us for
product marketing and product management
for quite some time people skills again
a soft skill so what was happening here
is when we interviewed the managers we
started seeing the trend that they would
hire for soft skills and then they would
train people in the hard skills that
were necessary a very interesting
approach so with that in mind and if you
choose to take that approach I'm going
to give you a couple of different
techniques in order to assess the soft
skills that might help drive people into
these new skill sets that are required
and as well as the ability to assess
some of the hard skills that are
required for the team so what we're
going to do is view these things in two
different groups there's a top three
here innovation thinking and the types
of behaviors and passions that drive
people to do what they do and then the
hard skills on the on the lower side
they're typically these soft skills are
very difficult to train it is possible
to develop them sometimes a good manager
can can do that oftentimes we see them
grow with experience sometimes their
intrinsic and somebody's character and
just who they are but the good news is
is that certain soft skills can indicate
a path to the missing hard skills that
we want to hire for and there are a
number of managers who are doing a great
job of that
and we'll share some of their techniques
let's talk about the hard skills the
first thing to do when you're assessing
hard skills for a team or for a
candidate is to categorize them into a
taxonomy what love or skills do we need
all right so this particular taxonomy is
one that's used by simple learn Andoh
MCP and a lot of the industry where we
have entry level so entry level in terms
of digital marketing skills might be the
ability to tell the difference between
the disciplines and to articulate the
difference between the disciplines and I
like to say at a cocktail party at a
cocktail party could you explain to
somebody the difference between paid
search and natural search could you
explain to so many difference between
web analytics and conversion rate
optimization level one is really not
something that we teach to usually
that's something people can pick up with
just a conversation and a little bit of
research level two we call conversant
level two is where somebody is able to
articulate the component level
definitions in each of the disciplines
so a couple of examples in web analytics
somebody might be able to articulate why
segmentation needs to be done or what
are the pieces of a key performance
indicator that it's ratio based they
might be able to articulate the
difference between the natural uses may
the on page optimization in SEO versus
the off page search engine optimization
they might be able to differentiate
search between the the search Network
and the Display Network so these are the
components of each of the disciplines at
a Scioscia tore articulate level and
this is appropriate for people who will
manage digital marketers or hire
agencies for somebody who may sell or
hire in the digital marketing room then
I see a typo there where that comma
should be won over I'll fix that later
the practition level is one of the most
popular practitioner is where somebody
hangs out of shingle and says I am a
conversion rate optimization specialist
I am a web analytics specialist this is
where somebody could build themselves
out in a consultant level or execute
within a company with minimal
supervision and it just so happens that
these map to the online marketing
certified associate level in the online
certified a professional level which
leads me to four master level this is
somebody who is considered a expert and
teaches at conferences sets the standard
creates new processes or identifies new
areas that the company or team can start
processing them so the first step is
when you're hiring for no hard skills in
the core area is map them to a certain
proficiency level now how can we
efficiently figure out what level
somebody is well typically levels three
and four practitioner and master are so
a proficient at their tasks that they
tend to share it with others so a great
pre-screening method before we even take
the time to interview is to have
somebody tell us if they've presented
papers and talks at conferences forums
and blog posts
let's have they shared their skill set
and this is a great pre-screening if
we're looking for level three or level
four sometimes it's in the software that
we're using to bring in candidates
sometimes it's so we can have somebody
do a pretty screen it's a great way to
find out ahead of time typically if
somebody has not shared and sent
typically statistically if people have
not shared on forums or blog posts then
they are less likely to be a level three
or level four it doesn't mean they're
not it just means that if you have high
numbers and you need to go with the
statistical outcomes that's a great way
to do pre-screening
all right once somebody's in for the
interview folks say well how do we
figure out what their hard skills are
and I'll start from the bottom here a
great question to ask is who do you
follow who do you follow on Twitter who
do you follow in terms of somebody who
teaches the skill that you need to use
in the role that we're hiring for so do
you follow Brian Eisenberg do you follow
Jennifer Carey oh do you follow Avinash
Kaushik and if they do it's likely that
they're investing at the conversin or
practice
level have you completed a book that
just browsed a book if you completed a
book which ones books that are reputable
have you completed brad geddes
Advanced AdWords book well then it's
likely that you've invested in level 3
practitioner skill set a lot of folks
claim certifications or that they took
courses a good thing to do is ask in
advance for a syllabus for that course
what was covered I can't tell you how
many people have come claiming to know
SEO well I'm certified I took a course
great what course did you take well
there's this one on udemy ok send me the
syllabus send me the link and we go
there and it's a great course four years
ago by somebody who was only focused on
on-page optimization okay so four year
old on-page optimization techniques
might be useful but it did not cover
keyword research it did not cover
reporting all required pieces of SEO all
right so when we go and look at the
syllabus this tells us how thorough
somebody's training might have been and
then lastly if there's an industry
association that you trust that has a
complete competency if somebody has a
course or certificate you can rely on
that by looking at what is covered or
required and it's really important here
to differentiate between tools
certifications and process
certifications so Matt I know that your
project management certified and that
was a process-oriented
certification that took a lot of study
and a lot of time it wasn't tied to some
tool now tool certifications can be
valuable it's great to know where to
click in HubSpot and it's great where to
know to know where to click inside of
Google Adwords those are very valuable
if you're going to be using those tools
but I do recommend that if you're
assessing some of these hard skills you
look at which certifications are
process-oriented that cover how they're
supposed to behave and what they're
supposed to do for success in that role
now I'm going to get into assessment
training and this is a hot topic some
people don't like to do assessments
hardly anybody likes to go through them
when we do assessments it's really easy
to make the interview go south so in the
next screen I'm going to share a couple
of specific
Smit examples that we use to look at
hard skills in digital marketing but
these will keep you on track so if
you're gonna do a snapshot of the screen
now would be the time to do that any
assessment that you give your candidate
should be undisputed by three out of
four experts who are already practicing
in that area if more than that dispute
if more than one out of four disputes it
then it's it's really not a fair
assessment for your candidate so check
if you have an assessment make sure it
it's a Thorat ativ and reveals what the
learning is number two we used to do
assessments here at market motive that
took sometimes half an hour and that was
a mistake and we learned very quickly
that some candidates would just blow out
get frustrated and think that's what it
was all about some people might even
accuse you of doing you know getting
free consulting from them and so you
want to be making be careful and just
keep it short and sweet and then the
other mistake that I've seen quite a few
times in assessment testing is that it's
some way of trying to figure out if
somebody has inside knowledge of the
company which is just not fair we always
allow somebody to choose whichever
company they may model and so you'll see
that for example we may say you know
show us a conversion funnel for our
company or another company that you
choose or might know so all three of
those are rules for assessments that if
you stick to those you'll likely be able
to make it through with candidates who
are happy and engaged in the process all
right here are a few assessment examples
that we put out for people you might be
able to guess which category each one of
these are in name three KPIs for a
company that you choose our company or
let's say you know Reebok shoes or sori
you can pick anything that you're
comfortable with what is what our apples
KPI is likely to be and this is a great
exercise for somebody to go through
build an initial keyword list for our
company or for a store that's going to
sell you know pretzel vendors right name
top five implicit data that you'd put in
a data management platform and if
somebody's going to be handling a data
management platform from you they should
need to understand explicit and
data one of my favorites is pick a topic
you're passionate about and write two to
three paragraphs and then instead of
letting them do this inside of Microsoft
Word or something we give them WordPad
which has no spell correction and no
grammar correction and it's amazing to
see you know for myself as well right
it's difficult we get dependent on these
things but if somebody is truly a writer
they should be able to write two to
three well-structured paragraphs without
a lot of outside help I love this one
40% of incoming links have an anchor
text of learn more what would you do and
you know if this is the reaction that
you get to any of these words we're in
some serious trouble because it's
unlikely that these people have the hard
skills and assessments can really own
assessments for soft skills get a little
bit more interesting so Google tell you
a little story Google used to be famous
for asking problem-solving questions
during their interviews and they stopped
doing that a lot of people assume that
it was because of legal issues or
because they were getting skewered on
sites like Glassdoor for asking Tufts
problem-solving questions but the truth
is that Google discovered or reported
later that they did not see a
correlation between the performance in
these assessment questions and the
behavior and performance once the person
was hired so that is an argument against
thinking assessment trainings and
problem-solving tests now I argue
because my experience has been quite
different and so have a lot of the
managers that I've worked with is that
Google was mostly hiring engineers and
they have other stringent tests and
exams for engineering that are more tied
to the performance of somebody who's
coding than a problem-solving test so
you decide whether these kinds of
questions will make sense again we go
back to the three rules you want to make
sure that these things are not disputed
they're solvable in very short time and
no insider facts are required but these
types of questions that we've asked here
all to give an example what we do in
Rand actually I love Rand straw what our
conversion funnel would be it's a great
question Aramark emotive John Marshall
and I picked up something from
duskie where the question is how many
curly telephone cords would you sell in
Santa Cruz and the we do require the
candidate to get to an answer but we're
really not concerned with the answer
what we're concerned about are the
things over here in this winter category
do we have a can-do approach is there
depth and capacity we like to say for
example for the mark tech type roles
that we're hiring for looking for right
now and that most managers are eager to
find data-driven roles is there the
depth and capacity how many chess moves
can one keep in their head at the same
time is their capacity for multiple
component problems something that could
be applied to learning these hard skills
over time as they develop
one of my favorite things if the
candidate is in the midst of an
interview and problem solving and they
use words like for instance or let's say
that to me that shows the ability to
plug in temporary variables and model
for a solution and that's a great way to
show that somebody who's not afraid of
failure not afraid of a few bumps and
they're willing to drive to a solution
using temporary variables so it's a
great sign and then the last key that we
love to see are ratios and sampling well
let's say that we stood outside of
Costco and we surveyed people and found
out how many had curly phone cords and
then we could apply that to the
population of Santa Cruz County any kind
of ratio and sampling thinking is
definitely going to lend well to these
new hot skills that we're trying to hire
for so these are great ways if you
follow those three rules these are great
ways to look at the depth and the
capacity that somebody has the ability
to think and hold a problem-solving all
the way to the end mat we've had
candidates who have gone through this
and done great and then minutes from the
finish line just blew out and said I
can't take it anymore I've done again
why don't you just could I wanted to
live a humor to it I know you've shared
this story with me but the one where you
think it was actually the the cell in
the the the telephone cords walk through
kind of what that scenario was maybe
some of the soft skills that you were
looking for and see how they approached
it and what did that mean to you
well some of the winners as I mentioned
before has been see people who talked
about sampling and so some of the
winners that we've seen have said well
let's see let's assume that the
population of Santa Cruz is 150,000
let's round it to 200,000 to make the
math easy to me that's a good sign right
they don't really care about the
explicit number but they're going to go
ahead and work their ratios so that's a
good one the second one was the sampling
I'll stand outside of you know Costco
and sample people walking out and then
the the idea that somebody the last one
is that when somebody puts out a number
and they finally get to a number which
by the way we're it's usually less than
like 20 because people don't buy for
like phone cords that often they just
replaced the phone or use a cell phone
is that when they arrive at a number and
you challenge that number that they're
willing to work their way back through
their ratios and adjust as necessary and
so those are all great signs but man I
think you're remembering there was one
situation where there was a PhD
candidate and he didn't realize that he
was the only candidate that we had
interviewed and he was just really
irritated by this question and this goes
to show where you have to be really
careful with these things and he
actually called me later to dispute the
question in the answer he was very angry
about this he ended up posting on
Glassdoor under an anonymous name and
and we called him and said look you know
and we know you're upset but you know
yeah he posted some things about mark
and motive saying it was like a college
dorm room which by the way at that time
was true some other things about our
numbers and Avenue that weren't quite
right so he was kind enough to take it
down so you just have to be careful how
you treat people and God as they go
through these things so a lot of folks
like to say well how can we figure out
people's work habits and passions and
this goes back this is a little bit
detached from digital marketing just
good practice right I like to see people
follow a method taught by a man named
Dell still it's a great book there at
the bottom of the slide high impact
higher and had an interview and select
outstanding employees and Dell taught
this method of taking the the work
habits or
mentions that you want in a candidate
and narrowing it down to three to five
cards or three to five we actually use
cards and we'd sort through them and
prioritize them three to five work
habits or passions or behaviors that you
weren't and then you ask the question
tell me about a specific time when you
did these things now that question has
become a little bit of a stigma in some
cases because it's deeply frustrating to
candidate don't have these now let's
take one of these for an example tell me
about a time when you influenced another
team for SEO compliance now what most
candidates will do just to slightly over
the majority are slightly over half they
will generalize and they will start to
say well SEO is important it's important
to get other teams on board thank you
for that I agree however I'm asking for
a specific instance where you influence
another team for SEO what was the
situation what were the actions you took
and what were the results and again
people will wander and generalize it you
have to pull them back interrupt and say
look I really need you to think of a
specific situation make up a name you
don't have to tell me the name but just
you use a name of somebody that you
interacted with if that helps now if
somebody really gets frustrated we just
we pull up let's don't worry about that
we'll come back to that later
but I can tell you that if your
candidate cannot name a situation where
they exhibited these work habits or
behaviors it is highly unlikely that
they actually have them okay and so this
can be a grueling part of the interview
but it is absolutely essential to find
out if people really can do these things
and have done them in the past when did
you direct a numark tech stack you know
when have you exhibited planning and
scheduling that worked well for your
organization and make sure and keep them
to specifics okay almost winding up here
on time but the most common question
that I'm getting from managers who are
working with us right now is Mike should
we hire inexperienced people and train
them or should we hire experienced
people who can hit the ground running
and it's a great question what's some of
the things that I think correlate with
each approach okay
first is if you're hiring inexperienced
folks it is more of an emphasis up here
on these soft skills an assessment of
the sauce just because it's highly
unlikely that they're going to have the
level three hard skills and the broad
level two skills that are required to
get the job so this is definitely a hire
and train situation you get youthful
innovation and energy in the company all
right but you really have to your where
your pay happens right where you do end
up having to pay is to make sure you
retain these people after you've
invested in them and that you keep a
culture that is attractive for them to
stick around alright the benefit is is
that you can shape these people provider
you can retain them to the needs of the
company and it turns out that there are
some statistics out there that show that
when you train your people they do tend
to stick around because that's
considered one of the benefits of the
company it's just like good health
benefits or or happy people and company
lunches these kind of things are ways
that people feel like they're plugged in
now on the other side you'll notice that
the shape is slightly different here so
now there's four experienced folks
there's much more of a focus on the
level three hard skills and level two
hard skills and we're going to assume
that the soft skills are developed as
they're going to get it's tougher to
recruit it's more expensive if you have
a team with deep structure already
established then you can focus on
specialists to come in and what's good
is that if you have experts in place
they can hire and guide entry-level
resources a little bit of in-house
training although sometimes it's tough
to get your best folks taking time off
to train when there are courses
available so that's something that you
need to decide on your own if your
company has very specific intellectual
property and processes inside then this
can work if it's doing digital marketing
it's on the bleeding front and wants to
stay up to date then it might make sense
to have outside classes the good news
here on hire experience is that mature
incoming candidates are more likely to
be better at representing the company
where that can be a trouble over here on
the inexperienced side but then again on
the inexperienced side there's a
communication methodology and ability
that we have in our
incoming younger recruits that they can
relate to their market much better so
those are some of the components that
help us decide whether we're hiring an
experienced in training up or hiring an
experienced and just pain the cost for
having them in alright interns get asked
quite a bit about interns and making use
of them there's a couple of guidelines
beyond the norm here that I'd like to
share with you the first off every first
off interns can provide incredible
resources and energy in your company
they can get a lot of great work done
but you really do have to be generous
and this is important every intern
should have a sponsor at the company or
somebody who is advocating for them and
watching out for them and so for the
interns that I got to sponsor here at
market motive and simple earn I would
simply ask what do you want out of this
but I have to ask three times because
the first time they would read off the
card if you will that their professor
told them side saying what do you want
to get out of this you're coming into
the leading digital marketing training
company and you know it's really
exciting there's a lot of what do you
want out of this and they would say I
want to make the world a better place
because I'm building my skills for a
future graduate it's like okay great I
know your professor told you to say what
do you really want out of this and
that's like it's the diligent ones who
read the card again but usually the
third time that you would ask they would
blurt out I want to open an e-commerce
store that sells textbooks that make a
ton of money or you know I want to I
want to you know get a career in in
analysis and move my way into finances
you know and what we would do is once we
could really find out what they want it
is we take it on ourselves to enable
them I had one intern come in and say I
just want to be a CEO and I want to do
what it takes and so from then on I made
it my job to make sure to enable that
within the ability that we could have
the company so for the one who wanted to
open an e-commerce store we carved out a
section on our server and we put up I
don't know it was WooCommerce on WordPad
or something like that or and yep and we
set them up with that so they could
practice with it for the one who wanted
to be a CEO and in some of our more
intense meetings we would invite him in
even if we were arguing
I would go and find him and I would say
Mitch come on in I think this is you got
to see this and we invited the interns
to our lunch meetings where we did our
company planning in reporting and
invited their input and those things
came back to benefit them and to benefit
us and I'll show you how in just a
moment when I talk about recruiting you
don't want your interns to be the voice
of the company I think that goes without
saying in a lot of situations but we get
asked that quite a bit and make sure
that at least 20% of the role is
creative sure you can make them go get
coffee and do the junk work that you
know the tedious work but but give them
something to brag about here at market
motive what we did as we said hey why
don't you go ahead and do a contest for
who can make the best display ads and
we'll test them on our display out
network and see which ones win in a
couple of them stock and now the intern
can go back to their family or their
friends or the professor and brag and
say hey we're creating ads for the
leading Training Institute in America or
in the world training create templates
to guide new interns interns come in in
these days are super smart they can do a
lot on their own a mistake would be to
spend two three days training them you
know with your valuable people offline
what we learned to do is just give them
a task in most of the time they'd rise
to the task and only interrupt when they
needed help each time you learn
something new we stuck it in a printed
binder yep actually printed with little
plastic sleeves the intern and they come
up to speed real quick now in California
unpaid interns are allowed but there are
some real strict guidelines and I really
urge you to if you're gonna go that
route check the law and make sure that
your compliance it just basically come
down to a point where it's almost not
worth it to try and do it that way here
in California but your laws may vary
from state to state but if you stick to
these you should have great luck with
interns and then there's some benefits
so next we're going to cover a couple of
things these are typical sources for
talents typical ways that we can bring
in talent you know through your own
social media that's fine you want to
broadcast jobs and opportunities and and
that makes sense
really recommend LinkedIn premium the
advanced people search is just
phenomenal you can find people who used
to work in your area if you're in an
area like in the Silicon Valley and
people want to come back sometimes you
can find people who used to work here it
is a great way a lot of our talent comes
in through this
ask your proponents to broadcast on
Facebook this has become a tremendous
resource for us and guess who is
perfectly willing to broadcast the job
are your former interns who just love
love love the company okay if you go to
them and say hey you know I've got a new
job opening for this would you be
willing to broadcast it to your network
you just amplified your broadcast of
your jobs from people who love the
company are willing to be a proponent
for it so those are typical sources for
talent let's look at a few that are
sometimes overlooked all right become an
industry member various associations
like the DMA or the American Marketing
Association or om CP and scan their
lists in the member lists you'd be
perfectly within your rights to recruit
off of those member lists if you go to
om CP org and look down the list of
people who have public profiles in some
portion of the certified have chosen to
have public profiles those are great
people to reach out to and then
conference speaker lists if you monitor
the speaker list for good conferences
like PubCon or SMX or click Z and look
for new speakers who just made it onto
the list oftentimes these are
up-and-coming people who remember if
they're sharing their skill of probably
a level three or perhaps even level four
and that's a great way to recruit
analogous departments at universities
this is a little secret that john
marshall and i used if we needed
marketing people sometimes we would tap
into the economics department if we need
a web analytics people we've happened X
this is the ability to take large
amounts of data and make decisions did
you know that salespeople tend to make
good paid search practitioners also post
a video of what it's like to work at
your company sometimes your interns can
that together for you and then here's
one of my favorites
invite a speaker to teach on a specific
discipline where you'd like to recruit
invite a speaker and this is a physical
presence thing brick-and-mortar have
them come into your town rent out part
of the Holiday Inn conference area and
put it in the newspapers put it out on
your social network that expert speaker
such-and-such published author is going
to speak on this particular topic in
town fill the room
those are your candidates people should
show up to listen to a speaker in the
area that you want to hire those are
your candidates
I've seen Simply Hired do this Gotham
invited Rand Fishkin of Lois to come
down and speak on SEO packed out the
room I would say there was at least 150
200 people in there all of those people
were recruited all of those people were
recruited to work for Gotham and it's a
great way to go all right last thing
I'll leave with you and this is some
people call this agile employment I just
call it good sense when we can match up
these three areas people skill and
passion with their absolute contribution
a lot of times people's passion doesn't
line up with what they're able to
deliver so let's say that somebody has a
skill and passion are able to deliver an
SEO capability with what the company
needs break the functional definition of
jobs as you know it and put together a
custom job for a candidate or somebody
that you want to retain all right one
example here is that we had somebody in
PR who is also skilled in fact I think
she might be on this webinar who is also
skilled in digital media and video
production and we asked her to have a
unique job shape of going out and doing
the interviews of happy customers and
corporate managers who had experienced
great training through simpler learn and
produce that as a compelling video and
then go back and drive that through PR
and those types of job shapes can be
phenomenal for making people feel like
they're making a difference to stick
around so rewarding through paying and
culture is good but oftentimes just
making somebody feel like they're firing
on on so often all cylinders makes all
the difference for retention
once you've trained up somebody in the
hard skills that they need so with that
Matt that's what I have to share there
is a small gift here if you want to type
in that URL there is a digital dream
team's book that was put together by
Avinash Kaushik Brian Eisenberg brad
geddes Jennifer Karia in greg jarboe and
a few others that shows how to build
motivate and manage digital marketing
teams if you copy that URL you can
download your FREE copy of that and with
that I'll turn it over to you if there's
any questions in the short time that
I've left us be happy to try and answer
those otherwise we invite everybody to
jump into market motovan I think you
might have a little survey to put up as
well yeah let me go ahead and I'm gonna
put up the survey just so it's we can
have that yeah all right so for those
that are just on the call if you just
want to go ahead and kind of read
through some of those see which one of
those options best or I think you guys
should pick multiple ones see which
one's selected for you but I said I want
to talk about about what we do and
Michael I appreciate you you spending
some time that's something that's often
there's a training company that over
gets overlooked of you know how do you
get the right type of skill how do you
get the right type of people involved
there to make sure that we are getting
good skill set I know as a manager in
training that I remember going through
some of those parts and we we use
something called behavioral interviewing
which was a similar methodology of tell
me a time when you did blah blah blah
blah and you know based on the type of
position you're interviewing for you
wanted to see how did they process
through it and your SAR was exactly what
we did of you you wanted to sign with
the situation what's the actions and one
of the results and and I found that to
be a very effective tool in my
experience it's getting good quality
people and how do they work how do they
they get there so I appreciate you you
explaining some of those so we're gonna
go ahead and enclose us what we do is we
will talk a little about what's what it
is that we have so for simply learn a
lot of the training we have here is
within there is the digital marketing
side
is through market motive and they have a
lot of different courses that are there
that talks about the different skill
sets those hard skills that Michael was
talking about having to work in the
different disciplines in the different
parts I am not as familiar on the simply
learn sign I know there are some skills
in there that that's that are available
to do some of the soft pieces or maybe
some of the other types of skills but
that's one of the links we want to know
if we can help you learn some those
parts simply learn is continually
developing new curriculum and finding
new pieces if there are ways that we can
help you with that let us know find fill
out some of the survey that we can help
there and we want to be able to reach
out to you so I'm going to go ahead and
close this the poll since we've had
enough time there so all right there are
some Q&A we've got about ten minutes
left or so so let me go ahead and
alright so there is uh so one of the
questions that were asked is here is Ray
from over in California had asked this
one is how do the best in class
companies incent diem employees to
invest some time in training the areas
that they think to do do not impact
their job such as SEO person taking
social media marketing and kind of those
cross areas can you make it in back to
their job so so in implementation of
training programs that include thousands
of people there's really two approaches
that we've seen that of voluntary in
that of it's a necessity to retain your
job or certain benefits of the roles so
the obviously the retention rate assume
the completion rate is very high in the
90s if it relates to your role I know
that one group who was in publishing who
had about 3,000 people go through the
training basically said you cannot make
a move laterally up for up at our
company unless you have your own CP
certification and so the completion rate
was in the high 90s on that whereas
companies who make it voluntary tend to
have completion rates in the 30s percent
so it's really just a matter of how
important it is to manage
people finished the set up a motivation
typically there are motivation
methodologies that we've seen yet at
hire such as public reward when it's top
down when it comes from the c-level
execs this is important to the company
and people who finish the training in
some manner like highest score or
soonest to complete her quickest to
complete get recognized by the senior
management staff that helps some go with
competitive which team ends up with the
highest score within the deadline and
completion rate and like a golf
challenge has really helped when you
have regional teams competing because
they are generally taking the same
curriculum to come up to a known
industry standard that method has worked
very well there have been financial
rewards sometimes there is public
get-togethers you know a little bit of
an ice cream event where everybody's
invited and there are certain gifts that
are handed out we have pictures of teams
where they posted their certifications
that printed they printed out the
certifications have posted those up and
it became sort of a badge and if you
walked into a department and they had
say you know 50 or you know 100
certifications put all that was a big
status thing so those are a couple of
methods I know that the account managers
at simply learn have worked with
hundreds of teams and can share with you
some great ways to motivate your team's
to go through the training so it's a
great question and let us know if that
answered the question for you yeah what
are the follow-up piece of that might
get do you do you think it's good that
when you're having those individuals
kind of cross train different parts do
you think it's good that they get a
little bit of experience than maybe see
four six months or so and then have them
rotate to a different discipline to kind
of get a little bit of each taste and
see maybe what excel they owe me they
excel in a certain area
what are your how do you see some of
those things or what do you think about
that so of course it's a good thing if
you're able to do it there are some
companies where the managers are so
buried and so pressed for deadlines that
that becomes a luxury and it's just a
real
and then there are some groups where
they press themselves to do this so I
would say at a digital marketing agency
or any agency that's performing billable
hour does that's a must do that's an
investment because it increases
available hours that one of your staff
members can provide for the company
inside of a in-house team it certainly
would bring benefit but I have some
sympathy for managers who aren't able to
pull that off so probably not the ideal
answer that our folks were looking for
out there that's just reality I mean
sometimes it's just hard yeah or as we
used to say around here sometimes the
answer is it's worse than you think but
it is a practice that I really recommend
strongly for anybody that's billable our
services okay
another just one of the questions I had
a couple comments actually came in
regarding the social media I think it's
one of your earlier slides where I think
was 53% of the individuals looking for
the job postings said social media was
kind of their primary piece within there
why do you see that as such a
differentiator that you know social
media social media social media and
obviously you know my wife Jennifer is
the one who does the social media
courses so we are very heavily involved
in that so I have some of my snippets
why but why do you see that as such a
big piece that so many companies are
looking for social media individuals as
to compared to the others other groups
sure and you saw that it dropped down in
terms of actual time and priority once
we actually surveyed where the time and
priority went I think mostly that it's a
buzz word and it's it's a little easier
to hire for again there's a theory here
so this is not something we've gone and
analyzed and got proof in but oftentimes
the algorithm for the initial report
that we have if it says LinkedIn in the
Job Description we're going to assume
that they're looking for somebody to
work on LinkedIn or Facebook or like
what we do is we differentiate
advertising those it says Facebook
advertising the word advertising is in
proximity then we assume it's an
advertising role but if it lists a
social media platform or
work we are going to assume that that
rule includes some type of communication
with your audience and we plug that into
social media so there could be a little
bit of bias on the report there but in
general if somebody lists those
platforms we put that into that category
and it is really the way that a social
media you're going into thin ice here
and I know that Jennifer would probably
have much more authority on this but the
you know the practice of communicating
with your constituents your audience
people who might buy or have bought your
product goes much beyond marketing and
so now these were full-time marketing
job postings so if they included that
then yes you know communication with
your audience is just happening that
much we would hope even more even more
than 52% okay
the waters a question is from Daniel
from also in California had asked the
question of how do companies deal with
selling multiple products that require
the skills multiple marketing managers
specialize in different channels yeah so
it gets tough let's say that you have an
enterprise product and then a consumer
product or let's say that you have a
product range that covers different
target markets and so we've seen people
slice their marketing teams in different
ways you can have product centric
marketing you know or you can have skill
centric marketing teams and you know
it's a touchy question it's like Mac
versus PC you have to be real careful
how you slice your team's in that sensor
what do you claim is best generally just
stick my neck out a little bit I have
seen category or product specific
marketing teams be slightly more
successful because again product
knowledge is something that's trained
inside every company brought up over
time whereas training for these specific
specific hard skills is something that
you can rely on training programs for so
I would much rather bring in a
specialist in you know radiative
detection and train them in how to
market you know via social media and via
natural search and via the other
channels
in hard skills instead of bringing in an
SEO specialist and train them in
radioactive detection and so there's a
slight bias towards product centric
multi skill set then going in with an
SEO who has to learn each of the
products and and I would kind of train
off that I think it could be an
advantage if you have a large company
that maybe you have your social media
managers who's helping to set some
guidelines or give some structure or
maybe is the response but you know there
is that individual like you said those
other skills that they can say you know
they can use social media to post and
discuss about you know the radiology
information but maybe it's not their
everyday job it's just a small segment
or good job so they can they can help be
a part of it and be of authority but not
have to own the whole process right
exactly okay good well I know we're
coming up against time here yep anything
else that we should cover
I'm just looking through which is one
real quick question I think this could
be a good one that a lot of indoor
individuals might find is how do you
measure the ROI when you when you send
your trail individuals or your staff
through training do you have any idea of
how you measure the ROI of was it a
valuable resource that we can measure
against that it can help to validate and
show the CEOs or others to say yeah this
was a good investment so that's another
webinar yeah are you to three second
answer Mike yeah well there's new
there's there's again there's there are
two schools out there and in there both
I see they both have valid points
the first is that and this is a bit of
an idealistic approach I have to confess
all right but the people who do it are
getting incredible results when you
start with competencies required for a
role and you teach to those competencies
and then you prove that people have
completed component level training that
relate to those and then you measure
that against their performance okay that
shows a successful training program all
right the competencies and job
requirements for somebody to reach a
specific goal are going to be related to
skill sets so let's say that your
on-page optimization needs to do X in
your ranking needs to change and
therefore your qualified traffic
Changez then there for somebody who is
trained in on-page optimization
techniques should relate to an increase
in relevant traffic through natural
search okay if you can map those things
from the original competencies required
for the job through the performance then
you have the ultimate ROI I believe
beyond that other groups make a leap
just like we used to with television
advertising or print advertising when
you do it you correlate the results to
the behavior but it's a little less
scientific and it's a bit of a shot in
the dark sometimes so it's actually hard
to do I know you wish I know that our
sponsors wish that we could say that oh
yeah there are very set systems and it
is proven for more scientific reports
that the best ROI you can get us in
training but at to be honest it's a hard
thing for managers to actually put it to
something concrete because there are so
many factors going on generally teams
who train perform better okay it's just
another thing anybody questions that but
it's like jumping in a cold pool at
first you know it's that initial jump
that's tough to do but once you make the
commitment it works I think the thing I
really want to emphasize and leave
everybody with is when the requirements
for training start at the top when the
c-level exact team says we are going to
commit to this and stick to it and we
are going to hold our managers to this
regardless of changes in priority and
regardless of deadlines we will have a
minimum training time of n hours per
week three to five hours per week per
employee and we will always hold that
sacred until we complete this program
those programs get the best results okay
and when they tie back to competencies
that's the biggest win I like it
give someone to kind of walk away with
him saying what do we want to do with
that so yep excellent well thank you
very much Michael I appreciate your time
and then taking the taken time out of
your busy day to talk to us and kind of
get there again this webinar will be
available up on the market motive and
they simply learn websites that you can
go through there if you do want to get a
copy of the slides please email us and
we will make sure those get to you so
alright and with that
hello everyone get through the rest of
your day and
go about your business so thank you
great all right thanks Ally